bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans
parlement hebdo bonjour emilie rayman
elle au sommaire aujourd'hui les patrons
séquestrés ségolène royal lance un pavé
dans la mare en déclarant comprendre
ceux qui agissent sous le coup du mépris
social sony caterpillar et autres
faurecia
le phénomène s'étend et agite la classe
politique
nicolas sarkozy dit qu'il ne laissera
pas faire top chrono
on repart à zéro justement sur le calcul
du temps de parole du président de la
république le conseil d'état demande au
csa de revoir la règle du jeu
pour le parti socialiste c'est une
victoire
et puis un sacré couac dans la majorité
avec le rejet du projet de loi anti
piratage sur internet
alors à qui la faute la droite dénonce
une manoeuvre mais c'est aussi l'absence
des députés de l'ump dans l'hémicycle
qui est mise en question est justement à
ce moment crucial n'était pas dans
l'hémicycle notre invité cette semaine
emilie absolument emmanuel je peux dire
que notre invitée n'a pas franchement le
sourire aujourd'hui roger karoutchi
bienvenue à vous et merci néanmoins
malgré ce contexte d'avoir accepté notre
invitation vous êtes bien sûr le
ministre des relations avec le parlement
et c'est vrai que votre vie n'est pas
rose n'est pas simple en ce moment
d'abord parce que c'est vrai que la
réforme du travail parlementaire que
vous portez à bout de bras fait grincer
des dents et notamment à gauche vous
avez c'est vrai des parlementaires ump
pas toujours très docile et puis une
gauche qui m a utilisé le parlement
comme tribune privilégiée et puis c'est
vrai qu'il ya eu cette sorte de cerise
sur le gâteau le couac jeudi dans
l'hémicycle sur le projet doit internet
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous savez analyser les
faits sur ce qui s'est passé sur le
texte internet
moi je vais vous dire je me bats depuis
deux ans pour revaloriser le travail du
parlement et pour rendre un peu de
dignité à la fonction parlementaire
je considère que ce qui s'est passé sur
ce texte internet mais en partie à bas
tout ce travail on assistait du mauvais
théâtre de boulevard
un théâtre de grand guignol que les
députés de gauche on reconnaît ce même
raconte même il se cache derrière un
rideau rouge comme au théâtre espace
hippiques massivement une fois
d'ailleurs le vote appelé ce qui veut
dire que quand je lis dans la presse on
aurait dû demander une suspension de
séance et tout c'est bien qu'on ne
connut pas la technique parlementaire
oui c'est un traquenard oui c'est ça
c'est un coup fourré traquenard appelez
ça comme vous voulez je veux dire bien
sûr que on peut se dire après tout bon
voilà ils ont fait un coup ils ont
réussi sont contents c'est de bonne
guerre
non je dirais que c'est de guerre contre
le parlement pas sur le texte le texte
toute façon sera représentée il pas cela
mais vous faites un ministre la cei ce
parlement responsabilité mairie
s'adresse avec le parlement il dit aux
parlementaires
à un moment il faut arrêter à un moment
il faut être digne de la république
à un moment il faut être digne de ses
électeurs et un moment se cache pas
derrière un rideau pour dire on va
rentrer à 10 pour changer la majorité
sans qu'on puisse plus rien faire
puisque le vote a été appelé c'est
ridicule c'est inadmissible et je le dis
sincèrement ça dénature la fonction
participe à votre lave ou de verrouiller
dispositifs relais rencensement voilà
moi c'est pas devait être reçue à ce
qu'il y ait des rideaux pas des rideaux
mais que votre majorité soit mais juste
présente la majorité elle était là elle
a été père besoin de vous le dire on dit
elle n'était pas là quoi elle n'était
pas là toute la matinée il ya eu des
votes
toute la matinée la majorité a gagné les
patins de sanctions comme l'a dit franck
riester pour ces députés de la priorité
ça c'est autre chose
si vous voulez dire que est-ce que je
considère que les députés de la majorité
devraient être plus présent dans les
hémicycles pas seulement hier mais sur
toute une série de textes
bien sûr que oui donc des sens que j'ai
un chien tilda langue si ça c'est au
groupe de décider c'est pas à moi
d'intervenir la gestion de vos parties
au président du groupe
mais moi je considère qu effectivement
quand les gens sont de permanence un
puisque il ya j'imagine dans tous les
groupes d'aidé des rythmes de permanence
quand les gens sont de permanence
il est anormal qui est le tiers ou la
moitié des députés qui sont en
permanence seulement dans le groupe
présent dans l'édition du principe des
sanctions mais moi je pense
la financière par exemple de dessiner
c'est pas à moi je peux pas décider de
sanctions financières sur les députés
j'ai pas ce pouvoir
mais non moi je pense qu'à un moment il
faut de l'incitation
c'est vrai que les députés qui sont très
présents devraient avoir que ce soit sur
la réserve parlementaire que ce soit sur
peut-être des rapports parlementaires
sur des questions d'actualité films etc
il devrait avoir un plus c'est anormal
que des gens qui sont tout le temps là
n'est pas plus que des gens qui ne sont
jamais là et puis on va dérouler
ensemble le film de la semaine le
journal le monde a dit le ministre dacic
parlement n'était pas dans l'hémicycle
alors vous étiez vous dites alors
premier point par définition un je ne
m'amusais pas il ya longtemps que je ne
m'amuse plus deuxième élément il y avait
des cmp au sénat et à l'assemblée mixte
paritaire mixte paritaire pardon au
sénat et à l'assemblée
j'avais été à l'assemblée au début sur
les commissions mixtes concernant le
collectif puis je suis reparti au sénat
puis revenu bon voilà je peux pas être
assis au banc de tous les côtés en même
temps mais sincèrement ni d'un côté ni
de l'autre d'ailleurs
on ne pouvait imaginer une opération
pareille peut-être à tort si maintenant
il faut que j'intègre dans le déroulé
parlementaire du mauvais théâtre guignol
et du théâtre de boulevard
ça va devenir franchement une fonction
impossible mais je le dis comme ça c'est
très important ça veut dire rien du tout
cher ami ça veut dire que je dis
simplement aux parlementaires vous
n'êtes plus digne de vos fonctions quand
vous jouez à sa voix là et je me demande
si ce sont pas les parlementaires qui se
cache derrière les rideaux qui devrait
se poser des problèmes sur leurs
fonctions de député à les merlans un peu
de sérénité pour visiter ensemble les
événements de la semaine on va commencer
avec le lundi ça tombe bien la pression
retombe un peu lundi après un week-end
marqué vous le savez par le g20 à
londres et le sommet de l'otan à
strasbourg
lundi c'est le moment des questions et
des polémiques après les violents
incidents qui ont eu lieu à strasbourg
en marge de la manifestation pacifiste
contre le sommet de l'otan
l'opposition accuse le gouvernement de
ne pas avoir fait tout ce qu'il faut
pour empêcher que des casseurs ravage un
quartier populaire de la ville si
gorille banes un hôtel en feu l'office
du tourisme saccagé une station service
entièrement détruite
l'espace d'un week end strasbourg a vécu
au rythme d'une ville en état de siège
samedi après midi dans le quartier
populaire du pont de l'europe 2000 black
blocks cagoulés armés de barres de fer
s'en prennent à tout ce qui représente à
leurs yeux le système capitaliste une
guérilla urbaine dans laquelle la police
se retrouve vite débordé on va reculer
les moyens lourds les véhicules et ses
rangs les sens
le bilan des échauffourées 49 blessés
300 interpellations des violences
dénoncées par l'ensemble de la classe
politique
ce que je souhaite c'est plus de
casseurs soient punis avec la plus
extrême sévérité
nous avons là affaire à une violence qui
est une violence très organisé les black
blocks c'est connu ça fait pas mal de
temps qu'il sévisse ils ont des méthodes
de ce qu'on appelle de guérilla urbaine
se peu excessif mais en tout cas
d'action violente extrêmement éprouvé
une violence que déplore également les
habitants du pont de l'europe
selon le les policiers étaient
omniprésents dans le centre-ville mais
quasi absent dans le quartier dévasté le
maire de strasbourg remet en question
l'efficacité du dispositif de sécurité
que là on a laissé effectivement la voie
ouverte aux casseurs maire de strasbourg
il est socialiste chacun le sait il
organisait accueillez
il a même favorisé d'ailleurs le
rassemblement altermondialiste il en a
récolté ensuite les fruits
la ministre de l'intérieur michèle
alliot-marie rappelle que 9000 policiers
étaient spécialement mobilisés les verts
réclament quant à eux l'ouverture d'une
commission d'enquêté sur ces événements
roger karoutchi on pourrait faire le
lien avec ce qui précède on a le
sentiment que le gouvernement a du mal à
anticiper un couteau et moi dans cette
affaire de strasbourg il ya eu
d'ailleurs plusieurs questions posées
assemblée nationale comme au sénat
je crois que les réponses du ministre de
l'intérieur michèle alliot marie sont
les plus les plus évidentes
nous savons qu'à chaque sommet de ce
type un gène ou ailleurs et u d'extrême
violence
nous savons qu'il ya à peu près 1500
manifestants qui venaient pas manifester
qui venait casser
d'ailleurs en cagoules et des boules
dans les maliens sûr il ya une
proposition d'ailleurs qui va être
présentée ci de mémoire par le député
ump didier julia qui dit si on ait le
droit de manifester n'est pas en cause
quand on manifeste on ne vient pas cassé
qui sache comment on empêche quelqu'un
portait une cagoule dans un cortège de
hobo suivre coûteux c'est facile en fait
c'est facile il ya des contrôles
policiers pour ça
la plupart des manifestations d'ailleurs
son protégé encadrés par la police et se
déroule de manière normale quel que soit
le motif de la manifestation on a le
droit de manifester en france pour dire
ce qu'on pense de tel ou tel élément de
la politique on est content vienne
cagoulés c'est que quand même on a des
intentions qui ne sont pas simplement de
manifester pacifiquement
sinon y'a pas de raison de ma des
cagoules donc si on se met des cagoules
c'est qu'on a bien l'intention après la
manif d'aller casser du magasin donc je
vois pas pourquoi on autoriserait ça non
mais dans le cas de ce qui s'est passé à
strasbourg
les effectifs de police étaient très
organisé méthodique bien encadré je
précise d'ailleurs que contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé dans les sommets
antérieurs il ya pas eu de blessés y'a
pas une mort alors il ya des
dégradations matérielles
bien sûr mais il n'y a pas eu il n'y a
pas eu de blessé et il n'y a pas de
morts et c'est quand même l'action
première de la police d' éviter quand
vous avez 1500 type qui viennent pour
tabasser cas c'est d'éviter ça je
précise d'ailleurs que je préfèrerais
voir la gauche dire que ce qui est
scandaleux
ce sont les 1500 qui venait tout cas
c'est que de dire est-ce que l'effectif
policier était pas trop est-ce que
c'était pas trop sécurisé etc
et le maire de strasbourg a une réaction
mesurée et et par la suite il a reconnu
lui-même tu es bien des éléments sur la
structure policière l'encadrement
policier avait été fait en accord avec
lui avant le sommet allez on avance
parce que l'actualité est riche c'est
vrai qu'en ce début de semaine il
apparaît aussi que la grande gagnante du
week-end politique s'appelle ségolène
royal toujours sur le devant de la scène
avec des prises de positions décoiffante
l'ex candidate aux et ça marche comme
lorsqu'elle dit comprendre ces salariés
qui retiennent en otage leur patron elle
choque mais elle est aussi en phase avec
l'opinion
un souci de plus pour martine aubry tout
de suite le décryptage avec fabrice
culine ségolène royal n'a pas raté
l'occasion en s'offrant une longue
tribune dans le jdd
la présidente de poitou charentes comble
une nouvelle fois l'espace s'est laissé
quasi vacant par la direction du ps ce
week end
au passage elle provoque une petite
polémique recadrage de son ex premier
ministre
c'est vrai qu'il y a un sentiment de
colère d'injustice dans le monde ouvrier
et syndical français devant les
conséquences de la crise c'est vrai
qu'il peut y avoir un certain sentiment
de radicalité il faut en même temps que
les forces syndicales qui d'ailleurs ont
ces deux visions et les forces
politiques de gauche contribuer à je
dirais à ce que l'expression de cette
colère de cette protestation soit en
même temps maîtrisée dans des formes
démocratiques dans des formes organisée
lionel jospin hubert védrine ou michel
sapin dans un week-end souvent qualifiée
d' historique la parole à gauche c'était
aux anciens ministres
pas une erreur de casting mais un
travail d'équipé
martine aubry est présente mais elle
laisse à moi comme à d'autres les
secrétaires nationaux le soin de
s'exprimer elle ne veut pas se
substituer à vis à vis de sa propre
direction je crois qu'elle a raison
c'est le contre sarkozy sarkozy se
substitue y compris à son premier
ministre
martine aubry veut faire marcher une
équipe ensemble ce lundi soir martine
aubry est sortie de sa réserve pour
dénoncer un contresens historique
vis-à-vis de l'otan et des avancées
limiter du g20
le souci du recul pour le premier
secrétaire la politique de la chaise
vide pour ses détracteurs à l'ats roger
karoutchi votre regard sur ces patrons
séquestrés par leurs salariés
est-ce qu'il faut uniquement tenir un
discours répressif ou vu le contexte il
faut aussi essayer de les comprendre
comme assembler essayer de le faire
ségolène royal alors je trouve que
ségolène royal vraiment jouer avec le
feu et que le parti socialiste ferait
mieux de réfléchir à ce qu'il dit et de
la manière dont il le dit qu'il faille
du dialogue social et l'année 2008 a été
l'année record en accords sociaux
contrats conventions etc
par rapport aux années précédentes qui
failli du dialogue social que dans une
période de crise économique avec la
montée du chômage que à laquelle on
assiste
il faille une attention particulière ce
que le fait le gouvernement en prenant
des mesures notamment par exemple sur le
réajustement de l'indemnisation du
chômage partiel sur les mesures pour
relancer l'activité ou l'emploi ça ça ça
participe du fait de se dire on essaye
de trouver des solutions ce qui n'est
pas acceptable parce que si on commence
comme ça et si on commence à le dire
comme ça c'est de légitimer les
séquestrations
parce qu'alors demain on légitimera le
fait que les élèves ses caisses leur
proviseur je trouve que l'actuel et très
irresponsable parce que si un jour ça
dérape
et si un jour une séquestration finit
mal qu'est ce qu'on dira et à ce stade
folie pour suivre ces séquestrations
faut qu'ils les poursuites judiciaires
ah ben moi je trouve que je n'en sais
rien ça dépend aussi de la nature
si ça dure dix minutes mais je crois que
si une séquestration et violence
et si réellement elle devait avoir des
conséquences lourdes
c'est illégal le voulait la légalité
elle est pour tout le monde et on peut
pas commencer à dire la légalité ce
partage en fonction des périodes où en
fonction de qui ça concerne ça c'est pas
possible on passe maintenant à la
journée de mardi
l'italien endeuillé minute de silence au
parlement français par solidarité avec
une italie sous le choc
le tremblement de terre très violent qui
a secoué le centre du pays a fait près
de 300 morts
le gouvernement italien après avoir
refusé l'aide internationale a
finalement demandé des financements
européens pour faire face aux
conséquences de la catastrophe
puis mardi c'est aussi l'outre-mer qui
revient à nouveau à la une de
l'actualité politique puisque les
députés entament l'examen du projet de
loi d'orientation pour le développement
économique des territoires ultramarins
un texte prévu de longue date avant même
l'embrasement de l'outre-mer l'hiver
dernier et pour yves jégo c'est aussi
l'occasion de recoller les morceaux et
de se revigorer après des semaines
houleuses
on écoute tout de suite le ministre
défendre son texte ce texte élaboré dans
les conditions vous avez rappelé depuis
bien longtemps depuis 2007 et issu des
propositions du chef de l'état dans sa
campagne électorale qu'il jette les
bases d'une refondation du modèle
économique qu'il vient rencontrer si
j'ose dire ce qui a été exprimé
largement dans la rue aux antilles et
dans les autres départements d'outre-mer
en ce début d'année c'est à dire celui
d'un modèle économique on doit favoriser
la production locale plutôt que
l'importation et on doit mettre l'accent
sur les problèmes sociaux notamment en
portant l'effort sur le logement social
alors le projet de loi sur l'outre-mer a
été adopté mais pour la gauche ce texte
est décalé il n'a pas su prendre en
compte le climat actuel dans les dom et
les revendications sur le pouvoir
d'achat
qu'est ce qui change avec cette nouvelle
loi chloé buffard
c'est un texte très attendu surtout
depuis la crise sociale aux antilles
mesure phare la création de zones
franches d'activités dans les
départements d'outre-mer avec à la clé
d'importantes réductions fiscales pour
les entreprises
plus largement c'est l'ensemble du
système de défiscalisation de la loi
girardin de 2003 qui va être revu
notamment pour relancer la construction
de logements sociaux il en manque
actuellement 62 milles et seuls 4000
sont construits par an pour faire face
aux revendications sur le pouvoir
d'achat la loi renforce les exonérations
de cotisations de charges sociales en
priorité pour les bas salaires
le gouvernement a aussi autorisé les
entreprises à verser un bonus
exceptionnel de 1500 euros maximum par
an et par salarié
ce texte sera prolongé par les états
généraux de l'outre-mer du 15 avril au
15 mai mais elie domota et le lkp ont
déjà annoncé qu'ils refusaient d'y
participer
justement est ce que ces états généraux
compte tenu de cette absence notamment
du lkp ne sont pas vouées à l'échec par
avance
pourquoi tant d y a pas que le lkp comme
acteur les états généraux de l'outre-mer
concerne tous les départements tous les
territoires concerne beaucoup d'acteurs
économiques politiques
le lkp et enfin monsieur domota dit je
n'irai pas très bien le politique de la
chaise vide n'a jamais été un élément
qui fasse progresser
en trois ans il collectif contre la vie
chère vdi là une chose de son bas malgré
deux syndicats d'accord mais enfin arte
merci les élus si les présidents de
conseils ci et parlementaires si les
acteurs économiques sont là on peut
avancer c'est ce qui se passera et je
crois que le texte d'ailleurs je le dis
puisque effectivement le texte sur
l'outre-mer qui vient d'être adoptée
était préparé plus longtemps mais il a
été au sénat largement modifié pour
tenir compte des évolutions
il a été à l'assemblée largement amendé
avec l'accord du gouvernement pour tenir
compte des évolutions
c'est donc un texte maintenant tout à
fait adapté sur la situation actuelle
allez mardi toujours revoilà ségolène
royal
oui très enfants cette semaine ségolène
l'ex candidate à la présidentielle et au
sénégal et en profite pour allumer une
vieille polémique qui a l'air de vous
ravir d'avancé elle demande pardon aux
sénégalais pour des propos tenus en 2007
par nicolas sarkozy le président avait
dit à l'époque dans son discours de
dakar le drame de l'afrique c'est que
l'homme africain n'est pas assez entré
dans l'histoire
ségolène royal qui se met au dessus du
président de la république voilà qui a
suscité évidemment un certain nombre de
réactions la gauche adorent la droite
est horrifiée on écoute ses réactions
trouve c'est indigne voilà c'est indigne
parce que je pense que nous devons être
capables entre la majorité et
l'opposition d'avoir toutes les
critiques que nous voulons tous les
débats que nous voulons mais dans un
cadre qui soit tout de même celui de
l'intérêt de la france soit là et que je
trouve profondément choquant car
responsable de l'importance
une responsable politique de
l'importance de ségolène royal à
l'étranger viennent critiquer notre pays
je trouve ça très choquant sur ce sujet
là comme sur beaucoup d'autres ségolène
et moi nous partageons absolument la
même vision de la france mais aussi des
valeurs que nous portons
voilà je je suis très heureuse qu'elle
ait dit ce qu'elle a dit j'avais été
quasiment les propos semblables en 2007
et je crois que les africains
apprécieront que les français tiennent
un autre discours que celui qu'ils ont
entendu du président de la république
alors votre regard sur la semaine
décidément très active de ségolène royal
moi j'ai dit que ségolène royal nous
faisait un tour du monde en 80 bourdes
je le maintiens franchement je dois dire
que pour quelqu'un comme moi entre
autres et avant quand j'étais sérieux
donc avant de faire la politique quand
j'étais à gages et d'issoire inspecteur
général des propos comme ça m'aurait et
continue de le faire de maury fier parce
que d'abord politiquement je veux dire
structurellement institutionnellement
seul le chef de l'état élu par les
français peut présenter des excuses
comme le fait chirac en 95 ou prendre
une position au nom de la france
à quel titre pardon de le dire comme ça
madame ségolène royal dit je viens
présenter le pardon ou demander le
pardon
elle a eu l'air de toucher juste emmener
en balade et effectivement elle n'a pas
là-bas elle n'a pas à prendre des
positions paille au nom du pays
on prend des positions et nos deux pays
quand on est élu c'est là y seraient
tels présidente de la république elle
peut dire ce qu'elle veut où elle veut
mais encore que sur cette affaire
africaine
moi non seulement historiens mais né en
afrique du nord
je peux dire simplement je dis ça comme
ça que les sons ses appréciations aux
historiens c'est pas si facile que ça il
ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
condamnables dans tout ce qu'a été la
colonisation et c'est vrai mais le côté
il faut uniquement faire dans la
repentance
je le dis franchement je trouve que
c'est une position qui n'a pas de sens
aller à l'assemblée nationale cette fois
à droite et gauche ne parviennent
toujours pas à se mettre d'accord sur un
nouveau règlement intérieur en cause le
plafonnement du temps de parole de
l'opposition
et c'est même un dialogue de sourds
comme le montrent les sorties cette
semaine des présidents des groupes ps et
ump en écoute la question est vraiment
posé à bernard accoyer président de
l'assemblée nationale je la pose même
plus au président du groupe ump parce
que je sais quel est son son son souhait
c'est effectivement de l'être le patron
de l'assemblée nationale mais au profit
de son groupe
j'en appelle vraiment solennellement au
président de l'assemblée nationale
si il persiste avec c'est ce projet de
rêve de réforme du règlement de
l'assemblée nationale
nous pouvons
engagé une bataille frontale je
rappellerai une nouvelle fois toutes les
ouvertures et toutes les concessions
nous avons fait au ps et elles sont
nombreuses
désormais nous partageons le contrôle et
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
gauche droite désormais nous partageons
les questions d'actualité à équité
gauche droite désormais il y a un temps
réservée à la gauche à l'opposition pour
présenter des textes de loi ça
n'existait pas avant
désormais il ya plus de 49 3 il faut
donc équilibré en limitant le temps de
discussion des textes voilà tout ça est
parfaitement cohérent il le sait il est
dans un jeu de rôle de posture moi je
rentrerai pas dans ce jeu et je crois
que bernard acoyer non plus alors on
arrive aux vacances parlementaires c'est
le temps d'un premier bilan pour
l'application de cette réforme de la
constitution censée d'ailleurs vous
l'avez dit donner plus de pouvoir au
parlement
est-ce que c'est pas un peu du trompe
l'oeil on voit les critiques à gauche
mais aussi une forme un petit peu de
mécontentement au sein de l'ump sur la
manière dont elle peut justement
s'investir dans débat parlementaire moi
d'abord je voudrais dire que la loi
organique était votée elle a été
évidemment évaluer par le conseil
constitutionnel qui nous a donné raison
et qui a validé la loi organique y
compris le fameux article 13 qui prévoit
le temps programmé donc alors que
d'accord la gauche ait dit ce qu'elle
veut mais vu son comportement et son
attitude je vais dire ce que je donc moi
je vous le dit c'est le temps programmé
la gauche nous a dit dans l'hémicycle
c'est inadmissible c'est
inconstitutionnel ouverte conséquence
ionel tranchera négativement là dessus
le conseil national n'a pas tranché
négativement là-dessus premières heures
de la gauche deuxième erreur moi je
rappelle que c'est en 1981 une assemblée
une majorité de gauche qui a dit les
questions d'actualité qui était
jusque-là égalité entre l'opposition et
la majorité est à 7 à la proportionnelle
ce qui fait que la gauche s'est pris le
paquet là maintenant c'est une majorité
de droite qu'ils disent est d'accord
égalité sur les questions d'actualité ce
qui compte beaucoup parce qu'elle
visibilité très bien
troisième élément on donne à la gauche
un certain nombre à la gauche à
l'opposition qu'elle soit un jour de
droite un jour de gauche peu importe on
lui donne des pouvoirs il va y avoir des
propositions de loi socialistes abordés
dans les autorités pourquoi vous n'avez
pas su la rendre consensuel finalement
mais la fête lui parce qu'en réalité la
gauche ne veut pas la gauche n'en veut
pas en réalité qu'est ce que je vous
dise on a fait beaucoup d'avancées
on a donné beaucoup de pouvoir nouveau
au parlement à l'opposition ou
minoritaire mais l'opposition
systématique le abba sarko sur tout et
rien qui se transforme y compris sur la
vie intérieur de l'assemblée
c'est un vrai problème alors là dessus
on a du mal à avancer plusieurs fois
mois des députés socialistes par exemple
lors de la révision constitutionnelle
monde et nous on est prêt à la voter
mais c'est comme ça politiquement la
situation étant ce qu'elle est par
rapport à nicolas sarkozy c'est non bon
voilà jean marc ayrault appelle la
bataille frontale allait passer de la
bataille frontale monsieur pas de la
bataille intelligente elle est restée
concentrée en face maintenant à la
journée de mercredi est désolé à nouveau
produire pour la majorité
alors bon
le temps de parole du président de la
république doit-il être décompté par le
csa en octobre 2007 le conseil supérieur
de l'audiovisuel avait répondu non
mercredi le conseil d'état a rendu un
avis différent je le cite le csa ne peut
exclure toute forme de prise en compte
des interventions du chef de l'état et
de ses collaborateurs
une formulation interprété différemment
par la droite et par la gauche frédéric
lefebvre lui n'y voit pas un camouflet
et françois hollande lui est ravi
on les écoute il a fallu que des
parlementaires fassent un recours
comme si la seule façon d'obtenir
justice était de s'adresser à au
tribunal en l'occurrence le conseil
d'état donc je savoure la victoire parce
que c'est une victoire importante du
droit du pluralisme de la démocratie et
je déplore qu'il ait fallu utiliser ce
recours là pour obtenir gain de cause
non pas je les dis pour l'opposition
mais pour le respect du droit
je pense qu'ils n'ont pas bien lu la
décision du conseil d'état vous non plus
visiblement parce que ce qui a décidé le
conseil d'état c'est de renvoyer au csa
et il réaffirme le principe ce qui est
exactement l inverse de ce que voulait
la gauche que le président de la
république ne peut pas être traités
comme les partis politiques s'étaient
sac demandé la gauche hélas le conseil
d'état l'a envoyé dans ses buts
bon alors qui dit vrai roger karoutchi
dans cette histoire naturellement
frédéric lefebvre mais non mais au-delà
de ça on va attendre sereinement la
réunion et la décision et les réflexions
du csa comme aujourd'hui nicolas sarkozy
est à la fois au dessus des partis mais
également un acteur politique majeur
il va intervenir dans les meeting pour
les européennes anti de la problème
véritable c'est que la vème république
fait du président de la république n'ont
pas un spectateur comme sous la ivème un
acteur bon sincèrement j'ai pas souvenir
d'avoir entendu le ps protesté lorsque
françois mitterrand avant un certain
nombre d'élections intervenait et
intervenez de manière systématique à la
télévision et c'est plutôt pour sa part
d'une réunion du parti socialiste comme
on appelle un président arbitre jacques
chirac même c'était un président en a
d'autres moi je trouve que là dessus on
a deux problèmes d'abord est ce que oui
ou non dans le cas de la vème république
il est normal que le président de la
république soit au dessus des partis la
réponse est oui
comment dans ces conditions des comptes
ont par exemple je vais vous dire même
même pratiquement le 6 juin il y aura
barack obama et le président républicain
il va faire un grand discours vous des
comptes et quel tronçon par rapport à
l'opposition
j'en sais rien comment vous faites sur
des grands discours sur l'otan sur la
situation générale de la france s
comprend alors comme vous dites silva à
des réunions plus politique alors est ce
qu'on prend juste ce temps là pour la
réponse de l'opposition sur les bosniens
de manière générale d'ailleurs
l'opposition répond il faut dire les
choses
moi je trouve que c'est très difficile
de regarder la prise en compte du temps
de du président la république alors
j'entends bien je crois que c'est henri
guaino qui disent il doit y avoir une
inflexion sur la prise en compte du
temps des collaborateurs et c'est
pourquoi pas mais sur le président la
république dans le cadre de
cinquième république moi je pense ici de
m'aimer mais je pense que sincèrement il
vaut mieux en rester à la situation
actuelle
allez le travail le dimanche maintenant
au sénat cette semaine les centristes
ont voulu remettre le couvert pendant
l'examen d'un projet de loi sur le
tourisme
deux amendements déposés pour permettre
l'ouverture dans les zones touristiques
ont finalement été retiré au dernier
moment sous la pression du gouvernement
qui ne souhaitent pas voir resurgir la
polémique en ce moment on voit ça avec
delphine girard
le suspens aura duré jusqu'au bout
malgré la controverse sur le travail
dominical
hervé mort et quelques minutes avant la
séance prétend qu'il maintiendra son
amendement
objectif permettre l'ouverture des
commerces le dimanche dans les zones
touristiques
ce que j'espère surtout c'est qu'on sort
d'une situation tout à fait ubuesque où
certains magasins ont le droit d'ouvrir
et pas d'autres où nos grands magasins
sont fermés ou des grands magasins de
luxe de réputation internationale qui
ont une véritable attractivité dans le
tourisme haut de gamme sont fermés le
week-end c'est surtout ça qui m'apporte
j'aimerais qu'on entre dans le 21e
siècle
du côté de l'opposition cet amendement
est au contraire un véritable retour en
arrière nous aurions été éventuellement
favorable à une abstention là nous
allons franchement voté contre ce texte
surtout pour cette question du travail
du dimanche de ce nouvel ballone ce
nouveau ballon d'essai qui est lancé
pour tenter de nous faire adopter à
retour en arrière de plus de son temps
après plus de douze interventions des
sénateurs la proposition du gouvernement
va changer la donne le régime actuel
doit donc être réformé le gouvernement
en ce qui le concerne est parfaitement
déterminé à ce qu'il y ait une réforme
de la législation sur le travail du
dimanche
je vous demande hervé maurey de bien
vouloir retirer votre amendement hervé
maurey et prend acte
il retire son amendement comme l'avait
fait plus tôt yves pozzo di borgo
les centristes auront réussi à relancer
le débat
mais le gouvernement reste encore dit
idée sur l'embarrassante question du
travail du dimanche on a entendu votre
collègue c'est pour quand la loi son
travail du drame je ne peux pas donner
une date comme ça ce qui est vrai par
rapport à ce qui vient de se passer au
sénat c'est que le gouvernement a estimé
que c'était un débat trop essentiel ce
qui était d'ailleurs l'avis de beaucoup
de sénateurs pour être fait voter au
détour d'un amendement qui se sont
rajoutées au texte mort donc là aussi ça
chatouille la majorité s'est formé il
faut réformer parce que ses portes avant
tout à fait l'avis d'hervé maurey sur
l'incongruité pour ne pas dire le le
l'aberration d'un certain nombre de
situations mais nous sommes en train de
travailler à partir de ce qu'a été la
proposition de loi de richard mallié à
l'assemblée nationale et dès que tout
cela sera prête naturellement ça sera
pas écouté je l'espère avant en tout cas
avant l'été 2009
donc oui c'est à peu près claire
mercredi en reparle aussi du délit de
solidarité une expression trouvé par un
certain nombre d'associations et reprise
par la gauche pour qualifier les
poursuites judiciaires qui peuvent être
engagées contre une personne qui porte
secours un sans-papier mercredi dans
plusieurs villes de france des centaines
de personnes se rendent devant les
palais de justice pour se constituer
prisonnier
leur slogan si la solidarité devient un
délit nous demandons à être poursuivis
pour ce délit
alors suite à ces manifestations eric
besson le ministre de l'immigration a
réaffirmé qu'il s'agissait de là selon
lui d'un faux combat en l'écoutent
songez qu'en 65 ans pas une personne pas
un bénévole n'a une seule fois été
condamné pour avoir simplement comme
10 ou comme je l'entends et d un
étranger en situation irrégulière en
ayant offert un repas ou ennuyant en
l'ayant pris en auto stop dans sa
voiture et c'est donc le délit de
solidarité n'existe absolument pas cette
affaire du délit de solidarité
c'est un écran de fumée pour masquer les
divisions et les désaccords du parti
socialiste qui veut surfer sur une
émotion mais qui est incapable de
définir une politique migratoire
alternative
voilà il n'en demeure pas moins que sur
ce sujet une proposition de loi
socialiste fait examiner dans les
prochains jours elle sera rejetée
laisser le débat ce faire à moins que je
cache dix députés derrière un rideau
rouge le jour venu mais moi je pense que
maintenant
maintenant je vais me transformer ça va
être geppetto et pinocchio et vous allez
voir moi aussi je vais cacher des
députés dans les 40 dans les caves dans
les combles on verra mais sur cette
affaire plus sérieusement je partage
l'avis d'eric besson
je veux dire on peut lancer des
polémiques dans ce pays et quand on dit
l'un des hits solidarité comme le
rappelle eric besson que personne depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale quand même
ce pas hier depuis la deuxième guerre
mondiale suivant personne n'a jamais été
condamné pour avoir apporté de l'aide
un sans papier on se dit on voit pas
très bien qu'elle soit les polémiques on
a inventé les esses utilisation devrait
fixer sur le terrain mais a suffisamment
de vrais problèmes de chômage de deux
difficultés de vie occupons nous des
vrais problèmes n'inventons pas d'epo
l'elysée les maisons plus royaliste que
le roi comme les nouveaux convertis se
sait pas si c'est un nouveau converti
moi j'aime beaucoup eric besson d'abord
parce que j'ai fait la campagne
présidentielle avec lui et ensuite parce
que c'est un type qui au delà des dd et
des clivages politiques
il croit dans ce pays croît dans ce
qu'il fait et pas c'est assez rare 1 et
puis c'est un petit peu d'une très
grande dignité
allez on passe maintenant à la journée
de jeudi un gros bug sur internet
voilà roger karoutchi a hâte de revoir
ces images
un couac un camouflet coup de trafalgar
voilà pour quelques unes des expressions
utilisées jeudi pour qualifié l'incident
ou l'accident de séance qui a débouché
on a dit sur le rejet du projet de loi
internet et piratage pas assez de
députés de droite dans l'hémicycle des
socialistes qui eux ont su se mobiliser
le tout pour un texte qui divise est de
toute façon au sein même de l'ump
un bug au palais bourbon c'est un sujet
signé julia le caureq qui est pour des
cons il a fallu compter les main levée
une par une le texte est rejeté
mais c'est bien à vingt-et-une voix
contre 15 que le texte hadopi protection
de la création internet a été rejeté ce
matin l'assemblée jean dionis du séjour
nouveau centre et nicolas dupont aignan
non inscrit ont voté contre comme les
élus de l'opposition
du jamais vu depuis 1983 à la sortie
dans les couloirs les députés
socialistes sont tout sourire là le vote
de ce matin et pour nous évidemment une
grande victoire politique
nous nous en réjouissons et nous nous en
réjouissons tout autant pour les
artistes que pour les internautes à loi
hadopi est morte politiquement mais en
tout cas il n'est pas mort du point de
vue législatif c'est roger karoutchi qui
est le premier à droite à prendre la
parole
je comprends que vous soyez déçu je
comprends que vous soyez obligés d'en
tirer les conclusions
c'est à dire vous à les piétiner
le message est clair à droite la
majorité dénoncent un coup politique est
donc très rapidement c'est le scénario
d'une nouvelle lecture du texte qui se
dessine
les élus de la majorité étaient
majoritaires dans l'hémicycle
toute la matinée et au dernier moment
entre l'appel dû voter le vote
hop on vous fait rentrer un groupuscule
de députés de gauche pour inverser la
majorité bon voilà ils sont contents
c'est un mauvais coup mais sincèrement 1
ça ne change rien puisque le texte sera
en tout état de cause adopté à la
rentrée mais un peu plus tard jean
françois copé le patron des députés ump
vient faire son mea culpa
un vieux proverbe qui dit les coups de
pied au derrière ça fait toujours
avancer
voilà donc je considère que nous devons
tirer toutes les leçons de cet accident
de parcours bien regrettable la nouvelle
lecture du texte aura lieu le 28 avril
c'est en tout cas le souhait de
christine albanel la ministre de la
culture
moi je suis prête à me battre pour ce
texte un contenu bien sûr à me battre
pour ce texte au plus vite
mais c'est sûr que c'est un set une
c'est une épreuve est vraiment je pense
que c'est grave vraiment pour le monde
de la création et j'en suis très voilà
j'en suis très touché c'est le texte
initial qui sera réétudié un texte sans
la double peine c'est à dire le paiement
de l'abonnement après la coupure de
celui ci cette version plus répressives
introduite par le sénat avait créé des
divisions au sein de la majorité
voilà alors vous a revu dans l'hérault
dans celle des quelques collages et
justin bonomo on vous sent quand même
franchement exaspéré voir dépité voir un
peu déçu par ce contexte c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu d'autres couacs par ailleurs
on se souvient des ogm est ce que vous
vous sentez aujourd'hui d'attac pour
être le ministére l'assuré par an
nicolas sarkozy jusqu'à la fin de son
quinquennat
si le phare le cil parlementarisme
aujourd'hui c'est si difficile que cela
non c'est pas le sujet d'abord jusqu'à
la fin du quinquennat yacco nicolas
sarkozy qui peut en décider et puis la
fin du quinquennat c'est en trois ans
c'est quand même
vous avez gremm de l'optimisme c'est
normal d'imaginer un moment évolué donc
on n'en est pas là mais si je suis amer
c'est pas seulement sur le vote d'hier
s'est pas seulement sur le vote sur un
texte
c'est sur le comportement je veux dire
je me bas gauche droite depuis deux ans
pour dire il faut revaloriser le
parlement il faut réaffirmer un certain
nombre de valeurs et tout sincèrement ce
côté grand guignol
aujourd'hui il ya un problème mais il ya
plusieurs familles on a le sentiment
qu'il est difficile ont été votées
depuis deux ans je doute qu'ils aient eu
beaucoup de majorité parlementaire qui
votait autant de textes d'un
gouvernement en deux ans donc ça veut
dire quoi des sujets qui coince sur le
terrain et c'est ça que vous vous
remettez vos unités
non mais le commerce du dimanche
internet parce que vous n'êtes pas avec
les mêmes sur internet on est en phase
avec tout le milieu de la création et
tout le milieu artistique qu'est ce que
ça veut dire franchement moi je regarde
l appel de plusieurs centaines d'acteurs
de chanteurs de réalisateur d'ailleurs
la plupart d'entre eux de gauche qui
disent c'est scandaleux ce qui vient de
se passer il faut très vite adopté ce
texte
qu'est ce que vous voulez quand on se
dit il faut soutenir la création en
france
et ben oui ce texte y contribuer et
zorro d'israël un coupable nicolas
sarkozy en ce moment est-ce qu'il faudra
décider si c'est de votre faute de seine
jean françois copé s'il faudra désigner
un responsable pas que c'est plus un peu
plus compliqué que ça il faut il qu'on
regarde quand y'a quoi zones à risque ce
qui est commode est une chose mais ce
qui est vrai aussi
la vraie responsabilité c'est wes
cannelle parlement aujourd'hui et dans
quelles conditions peut travailler
demain voilà mais à partir de là moi je
pense qu'il faut que tout le monde est
une affection à gauche comme à droite à
gauche pour les mauvais coup à droite
pour la mobilisation jeudi les
universités toujours en ébullition du
coup l'inquiétude monte à la proche des
examens avec le risque d'une année
perdue ça fait maintenant dix semaines
que la plupart des facs sont bloquées ou
perturbées
coup de projecteur sur les étudiants
étrangers qui s'estiment pénalisés là
réputation des universités françaises
est en jeu reportage à la sorbonne flora
sauvage ces trois étudiants hollandais
sont inquiets à quelques semaines de la
fin du semestre et sont loin d'avoir
validé leur module car la sorbonne est
en grève
le risque c'est qu'il ne puisse pas
valider leur diplôme quand ils
retourneront dans leur pays
la grève dure depuis début février en
fait depuis que le semestre a commencé
du coup on va à l'université tous les
jours et parfois on arrive à rentrer
parfois on est refoulé pour ken comme
pour marco la lassitude a pris le dessus
très compliqué parce que souvent les la
sorbonne fermé par la police et nous ne
ne peuvent pas suivre nos cours de son
côté la sorbonne redoutent que les
universités étrangères remettent en
cause leur partenariat
mais pour l'instant la priorité est aux
étudiants étrangers
sur les 280 étudiants programme des
changes qui sont présents physiquement à
paris au second semestre
nous sommes surtout inquiets pour les 55
qui sont arrivés pour le second semestre
donc ceux qui n'ont pas eu au premier
semestre pour créer des contacts à
caissons signant avec leurs camarades
pour ce film familiariser avec paris de
plus la question des bourses erasmus
risque de se poser dès lors que ces
étudiants ne peuvent pas passer les
examens
évidemment ils n'ont pas de crédit la
commission européenne peut décider de
leur réclamer le remboursement de ces
bourses puisque les les examens
cautionne justement si c'est leur
formation on va faire le plein comment
votre cousine à certains étudiants qui
ont perdu patience il y en a deux ou
trois brésiliens qui sont partis ou
certains même renoncer à venir au second
ce n'est ce pas ce qu'ils avaient
entendu que effectivement les cours
d'eau ne fonctionnait pas et que et que
là là effectivement on joue serré car si
la grève continue certains pays risquent
de remettre en cause des conventions qui
les lient avec les universités
françaises elles et on passe maintenant
à la journée de vendredi avec cette
question bouteflika et ils président à
vie vendredi donc résultats des
élections en algérie dont tout le monde
bien sûr connaît le vainqueur le
président sortant abdelaziz bouteflika
alors tout de suite
retour sur ce vote c'est vrai un peu son
passion avec mathieu verlaine ça y est
c'est officiel
abdelaziz bouteflika vient d'être réélu
à la tête de l'algérie et le résultat
est sans appel
90 % des voix pour le président sortant
de quoi entamer un troisième quinquennat
sans inquiétude mais pas de réel
plébiscite sans une participation à la
hauteur
c'était la grande incertitude de cette
élection en 2004 en effet l'abstention
avait marqué les esprits le scrutin
n'avait fait se déplacer qu'un peu moins
de 60% des 20 millions d'électeurs
algériens
l'appel aux urnes a cette fois été
entendu puisque le taux de participation
a atteint 74 5%
le chef d'état avait fait des résultats
de ce scrutin une priorité lors de sa
campagne
il faut dire qu'à 72 ans et défendant le
bilan de deux mandats présidentiels
abdelaziz bouteflika vous l'êtes ainsi
asseoir sa légitimité
malgré les soupçons de fraudes dénoncées
dès hier soir par l'opposition
il semblerait que son objectif soit
atteint un commentaire sur ces élections
en algérie
je serais bien en peine de me mets
élections en algérie bouteflika
visiblement porté un très gros succès
avec un beau taux de participation de 75
% ces biens est incontestablement dans
un monde en afrique du nord ou
il ya un certain nombre de deux
d'éléments de troubles
je pense qu'on peut penser d'un score à
90%
je pense que pour beaucoup d'algériens
il représente la stabilité et la
continuité on peut de la critique sur
l'absence de démocratie l'absence de
pluralisme de la société
bah quand même là c'est une élection
présidentielle à la soviétique ou part à
la société qu'il n'y avait même pas
d'élection donc c'était mieux c'était
différent
non moi je pense que beaucoup
d'algériens se disent que quel que soit
le système
il leur faut être rassurés protéger et
est resté dans la continuité
ceci étant je ne pas mêler sincèrement
des élections en algérie merci en tout
cas à roussillon vous souhaite prenez un
peu de vacances avait coûté parlement
hebdo va en prendre un petit peu on va
se retrouver très prochainement merci en
tout cas d'être venu sur ce plateau pour
cette semaine particulière emilie on se
retrouve très bientôt bonnes vacances à
tous pour ceux qui ont la chance de
partir à bientôt
prenez les chemins de traverse
prenez le temps de penser tout de suite
sur lcp assemblée nationale le succès
politique du g20 peut-il modifier le
cours de la crise et redonner confiance
aux français
quelles conséquences sur les décisions
du gouvernement invité de questions
d'info cette semaine eric woerth
ministre du budget questions d'info en
partenariat avec la fp et france info
c'est aujourd'hui à 12h30 sur la chaîne
parlementaire assemblée nationale
très bien fernando se présente comment
les contrats échéance mars il faudrait
que j'en achète de vendredi est fou
qu'est ce qui te prends j'aurais dû
clôturer la position lundi à la première
heure et assumer les pertes
au lieu de ça j'avais attendu que leur
fille ils avaient bougé mais pas comme
je voulais je me trouvais avec un plus
gros déficit que je vais passer sous
silence les banquiers se sont ils pris
pour des dieux de la finance
nous en parlons ce mois ci dans l'autre
séance le rendez vous cinéma de lcp à la
fiche le film traders véritable thriller
boursiers dans lequel ewan mcgregor joe
nick leeson ce courtier britannique qui
provoqua un séisme financier
au milieu des années 90 avec nos invités
nous verrons nous